so I said the show got hit by
controversy last night nyle dimarco
performed at viet knees waltz that huge
people to tears but then there was some
anger when the judges totally messed up
his score Nyles former top model boss
Tyra Banks driven to tears thinking she
saw him get three tens but where were
those tens on the graphics he did get
three texts
max told us the mix-up was old man his
what 130 going 150 so so he can hear
very well in a worse screaming 10/10
complements me got the best dance of the
week so I'm happy with that
despite that controversy neither is in
first place but there was more drama max
versus Kim field switched up partner Keo
it's literally not a Viennese Waltz this
looks like half a step of ease wolf I
can't even criticize the Train
quick backstory Kiyo's usually with
Jodie Sweetin last night Jodie was
paired with Val who is Mac's brother
they came in second so is there
favoritism Mac says no I'm his friend I
hope he's still mine but he has to
definitely has to step up I did this job
for 10 years you're gonna come and
replace me
basically you better you better bring
what I used to bring me if anything it
just like fires him up to do better
Jodie also reacted to the loss of
actress Doris Roberts her grandma on
full house she will always be a piece of
you know full house history and we lose
one